ah shortening managers I'm with a Mickey
can tell us her I'm but Aneesa really
taking odds on the bottom is from Devon
sang in the slime he's a loving the
enemy spine he'll be here in the manga
online looks like i'm dividing to be my
talent up a que no tenga me shy hello
ish pm hi im sue carney chowdhury AKA
ali us and i'm a rapper from Munich
alyas featuring namaka on his third
album euphoria which reached number six
in the german charts in april the rapper
is already working on new ideas with
collaborators the rapper's family
originally hail from Islamabad not that
I'm say someone but my dad came from
over here pakistan in 1961 Pakistani all
the way to Munich of mentioned and the
city remains his home to this day born
in 1979 he was the only kid in his class
from an ethnic minority family and there
were certain times of the year when he
felt particularly like an outsider here
at humans gifu here I have always had
the feeling at Christmas that I was
under house arrest because you were the
only one not invited Kim Yuna you'd be
told you had to go home there's
something this rules we only need to
lose it for her but my mom would then
always put on a special spread for us
then yeah no extra of catastrophic
adicta out and about with fellow rapper
Kolya at a Munich beer garden Ali oz is
a born and bred Bavarian but often
travels around the world to shoot videos
the 2014 video for a hoodie and chucks
was shot in Cairo
to me
Ali haces not one to mince words his no
nonsense rhymes have repeatedly rubbed
certain people the wrong way naturally
sweet Mohammed not truly mark on us if I
know it messes people up then that's all
the more reason I could come up with a
more subtle and perhaps a more charming
solution Sharma why should I that for me
is the preferred approach things even
worse this fossil of the gig that of
kamat wid da stronda done in 2015 Elias
tackled the subject of racism in a wrap
off with pretty mo where they
alternately address common negative
stereotypes on all sides of modern
Germany
visa market oxy bus tricky of Quran
Shula I'm skits Upali at response to a
string of incidents he experienced while
growing up
devauden kindergarten Kinta fuss one
stunnas off on a mom on me one kid from
my end cut and asked me and my mom why
we wouldn't go back home to where we
came from lit their phone kafka shoes we
were stunned into and I saw the same guy
ten years later at the beer festival
saying at a table with neo-nazis of
neo-nazis alter citizen Z alyas learned
to challenge the narrow mindedness
verbally his philosophy broadening your
horizons through travel a notable
example being the tracks temple impasse
or stamped in your passport hopman on
envision some competition it's like a
bargain bin well you take a bit of
everything different to contain human
and with music to something good is
bound to turn on Zeke or from when you
draw inspiration from a variety of
sources the end product will be more
diverse and more exciting future to go
on span endure
a multi-faceted man in many ways munich
native ali oz she come against turn in
the gentleman's car I'm let's not end in
heaven sup brah mute avoid and fiendish
sample impasse